[Music]
did you do any chorus singing while
you're there core any any singing it
over your performance kid I mean I did
like play since if I was always a
terrible terrible singer but like
sometimes for jobs I've had to memorize
lyrics to things like foreign movie Step
Brothers and look at what you hear did
come out
that came out in thank you very much you
at least EFT in other words you're in
alright so so what did you have to
memorize for stepbrothers I had to
memorize the lyrics to Ice Ice Baby
because there's a scene where I it's I
think it's cut down to like one second
in the movie but when we shot it I had
to do a choreographed dance to the
entire song and lip-sync the entire song
but the lyrics were actually they were
tough to to memorize because they don't
make sense so I like figure out in my
interpret them for myself and figure out
how to make them stick in my brain by
having them make sense give us an
example
yeah I actually had them print out the
lyrics for me backstage tell me you
don't always keep the lyrics to a size
maybe in your jacket
no just the rest of his songs yeah I
think there's one called I love you this
super good okay so this is Ice Ice Baby
so the the the first links to the song
are yo VIP let's kick it which i think
is a nice way to start out a song
because it's saying like you're you're a
very important person let's begin let's
begin
and then the next lyric the next lyric
is alright stop which is strange because
we literally just stop
but fine stop alright stop collaborate
and listen which makes sense because if
you're going to collaborate you
absolutely have to listen ice is back
with my brand new invention which is I
don't know like are we gonna collaborate
or we're going to talk about your newest
berry and then it goes on to something
grabs a hold of me tightly then I flow
like a harpoon daily and nightly like a
harpoon is a huge it's like a spear
which is the size of like a large person
yes and I don't it's not something that
flows know but he's saying he flows like
a harpoon all day and all night
yeah to the extreme I Rock a mic like a
vandal light up a stage and wax a chump
like a candle I have to say those are my
favorite lyrics not just in that song
but maybe and I loved I use that all the
time I'll wax a chump like I can't I'm
gonna leave those ones alone I do that
yeah test